wenn das licht angeht die züge rollen
dann sind sie auf ihrem dachboden dem
himmel ein stück näher
3 herr alle um die 70 und seit mehr als
einem halben jahrhundert
leidenschaftliche pendler
beim us star sei es auch im wohnzimmer
einmal so aus freier blick über bern mit
einem bisschen kindlichem gemüt auch das
wie eine spielzeuglandschaft aus
hier wuchs hans-ulrich grunde auf der
das spielen und seine erforschung zum
beruf gemacht hat und auch für unsere
pendler ein land zerbricht realisieren
jens feckler jenseits von zeit und ort
viel im kopf oder im kopf frei und
dadurch sie vom werk zudem bessere
geistige gesundheit wo sie tolerant
gegenüber dem euro einlass machen
gegenüber allen anderen noch mehr
spieler erwachsenen spieleabend im
legoland oberhausen unter einsteins
wachem blick ein stein als
wissenschaftler seine gedankenspiele
haben etwas mit dem spielen gemein
es sind die scheinbaren fehler und
kleinen ungereimtheiten die spielen de
und wissenschaftler auf den richtigen
weg führen können
die nicht gewollte nebeneffekte wirklich
beachtet das was sieht seitz abspeckt
wärme fantasiert und das wo abspeckt
mehr wirklich bewusst aufnimmt als
autofahrer beachtet und osterfeld und
lehre durch das wissenschaftliche haut
geistesblitze beim herumspielen
viele wissenschaftler haben durch
scheinbare fehler ganz nebenbei große
entdeckungen gemacht
per spencer war so ein spieler der an
generatoren für radaranlagen bastelte
als ihm plötzlich der schokoriegel in
der hosentasche schmolz hitze durch
mikrowellen hatten frühere
wissenschaftler als fehler abgetan
pasi spencer spielt weiter mit dem
effekt unter findet die mikro männer
ein gedankenblitz aus zürich anfang der
80er rohre und billing entwickeln an der
eth das rastertunnelmikroskop wofür sie
1986 den nobelpreis bekommen gerd
binning bezeichnet die tätigkeit seines
teams dezidiert als spielen und das
mikroskop nur ein nebenprodukt seine
forschung zurück im legoland ein ganzes
fußballstadion haben inzwischen drei
unserer kindsköpfe gebaut obwohl sie
keine fußballfans sind es geht uns
spielen als geistige erholung und
inspiration durch lego ich kein komplett
meine gedanken freien lauf lassen was
zusammen bauen was eigentlich nicht der
anleitung entspricht ich bin maschinen
also maschinenbaustudent und da muss man
auch um die ecken denken vielleicht wie
meine maschine vielleicht so skizziert
und wenn man sich das bildlich vorstellt
und das dann so realisiert richtig
spannend als konstruktionstechnik daheim
in bunten bern sieht dass unser pädagoge
ähnliches spiel wo fand dass sie
wirklich wichtig werden sagt den radler
für sein kann darin versinkt ist der
prozess zentrales produkt was uns auch
und ist völlig in gebundener spiel mehr
geleitet ist vorstellbar dass punkt sei
auch ein wichtiger faktor ist aber
winter springs fantasie spielverlauf so
wie sie werden ihm wichtig was nachher
es muss also nichts dabei herauskommen
bei diesem herumspielen
gleichwohl ist das freie spielen eine
wichtige bedingung dafür dass auch mal
ein genialer funke entspringt sogar mir
noch
für den kulturwissenschaftler johan
huizinga ist aller kultur am anfang
etwas spielerisches eigen sowie in
pieter bruegels wimmelbild erproben wir
spielerisch das kulturelle miteinander
denn der homo sapiens ist ein homo
ludens ein spielender mensch wer hätte
das gedacht
unser drei bänder sind eigentlich
kulturschaffende potenzielle genies
sogar ganz sicher aber geistig kern
gesunde kinder mit falten im gesicht